what you're seeing was built by one man  pebble by pebble over 33 years  one morning mailman ferdinand chaval  stumbled across an interesting looking  stone on his delivery route  he picked it up  and from there an obsession began  using stones he collected on his walk  chaval worked each night without any  formal training to build what is now  called the palais ideal  the final structure is 85 feet long and  300 feet high  it mingles chinese algerian and northern  european influences to create a  fantastic and completely original castle  of grottoes  [Music]  he opened the palace in 1870 for the  public to enjoy  in his own words he says  you start wondering if you have not been  carried away into a fantastic dream with  boundaries beyond the scope of  imagination  [Music]  and this incredible bizarre and unique  place  does look like something you could only  see in a dream  [Music]  you